fébrilité et tension pour l'un des
témoignages les plus attendus de la
commission
nerveux montré du doigt pour sa gestion
de la crise des camionnettes il compare
l'arrivée du convoi le premier week-end
à un coup de poing son corps de police
dégarni a été surpris par l'ampleur du
mouvement
ému peterslory explique que ses agents
ont fait de leur mieux dans des
circonstances inhumaines
il faisait trop froid dit-il et c'était
trop malgré les avertissements dans les
rapports de renseignements piteux
s'attendait à une manifestation d'un
week-end de seulement
il reproche aux autorités fédérales de
ne pas lui avoir assez fourni de
renseignements sur ce mouvement plus
ampleur nationale
quand on lui demande s'il avait les
pouvoirs légaux d'empêcher les camions
d'entrer dans la ville à notre histoire
je ne suis pas un avocat répond-il
piteux slowly a été appelé à expliquer
une déclaration controversée
il n'y a pas de solution policière à la
crise disait-il le 2 février
la société civile et les trois ordres de
gouvernement a-t-il précisé Peter slowly
reconnaît qu'il y a eu des retards et de
la confusion dans la réponse du haut
commandement de la police d'Ottawa
sa responsabilité combatif il n'y avoir
été inflexible ou avoir retardé
l’intervention en s'opposant par exemple
à la négociation avec les manifestants
un mensonge a-t-il martelé mais au plus
fort de la crise quand son autorité
était remise en question jamais Peter
slovie n'aurait considéré céder les
reines à d'autres corps policier en 30
ans il n'a jamais vu ça à café
leur n'était pas au miaou culpa après
avoir été ciblé par tant de critiques
l'ancien chef pouvait en faire riposter
et donner sa version des faits il refuse
de porter la responsabilité de cette
débâcle mais pour lui le combat n'est
pas terminé son contre-interrogatoire
qui commence lundi s'annonce corset ici
Louis Blouin Radio-Canada Ottawa